if we're gonna play games the good cop
bad cop routine not exactly never start
with the head the victim gets all fuzzy
you can't feel the next see you wanted
me Here I am I wanted to see what you do
and you didn't disappoint you let five
people die then you let them take your
place even to a guy like me that's cold
worst end those mob fools want you gone
so they can get back to the way things
were but I know the truth there's no
going back
you've changed things forever and why do
you want to kill me oh I don't wanna
kill you what would I do without you go
back to ripping up my dealers no no no
no you you complete me you're a garbage
you kills for money don't talk like one
of them you're not even if you'd like to
be
to them you're just a freak like me I
need you right now when they don't
they'll cast you out like a leper
you see their morals their code it's a
bad joke we've dropped at the first sign
of trouble the only as good as the world
that allows them to be I'll show you
when the chips are down these uh these
civilized people they'll eat each other
see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve
you